[Música]
olá a todos
vai hoje vou falar se tiver segurança
como já foi dito mas na realidade eu
quero falar sobre se viver em segurança
eu não acredito que a segurança
informática que exista é bom pra mim
o trabalho tem que falar aqui falar um
pouco sobre o tópico do sacas
existem três tipos de notícias todos os
dias
fez bem como um trabalho
mas como eu vou preso porque eu falo
sobre isso
não existem três tipos como dizer que
não são criminosos e falando agora sobre
o universo nezinho que quer se ver
segurança
nós temos que viajar no passado não
fosse este o tema do ted
ao viajar no passado nós temos
perspectiva é que as guerras funcionava
e como é que as guerras continuavam no
passado nós tínhamos um tempo e um motor
de crimes por crimes estava e estava até
encontrar uma defesa tonel até meados do
século passado aconteceu isto não
consegue encontrar vulnerabilidades nas
despesas não vão matar a minha revolta
contra civis passar é a mesma coisa que
nós temos as nossas muralhas são
substituídas por firewalls temos nossa
cidade nós aqui são os nossos dados que
nós queremos proteger e temos os igual
mesmo assim acrescenta contudo que você
já ouviu falar em vários sites que
alguns exemplos vêm dando há uns anos
além de fazer isso virou vilão bane
encontrarem seu estilo ao site inicial
de venda
o ataque surge times aconteceram alguns
anos este bastante interessante o que
está acontecendo aqui
quem quiser pode consegue ser exatamente
o que aconteceu basicamente passa não
vai funcionar
o harley matrícula só que não tá ali
matrícula além de um código malicioso
que acontece com a história é pagar
vazado muito bom pois tira móveis mas
como comentou
há sempre as bombas atômicas estão
ransomware vocês têm ouvido falar nos
últimos três anos pra cá essa mulher não
tem mais nada a idade
basicamente nós somos fãs do tmx horas
para pagar em 20 com isso da maneira que
os entenderem os dados só de bloquear
isso aconteceu para os comboios ou mais
não cessava adote pano e para o sistema
de saúde inglês estão as chamadas bombas
nucleares a outra
este é o mais atual é o que acontece mas
a gente se pergunta quando vocês dizem
o país 50 por cento seguro e resseguro
99% seguro dizer que estamos sempre
gravar estas unidades vão encontrar um
buraco e vamos roubar os dados de
segurança somos nós somos nós são as
pessoas
isso acontece todos os dias em todas as
empresas
alguém diz o diretor da área de
segurança se eu estou muito seguro o
empregado é isso a meta passou não é
grande já que virão já todos foram
departamento finanças certeza
assistência social e já viram aos
políticos com pastores isto
isto é a nossa realidade é só agora o
que diz ti-ti-ti que smartphones em
portugal existe em cada 13 em quatro
pessoas três têm um smartphone home
banking
nesse marson eu diria que 1 em cada 4 a
2 em casa 4
já o barcelona para chegar quando
ganharam hoje o wifi ac/dc nós lá mas
algumas pessoas né
e quando eu aceitei vir até eu disse eu
vou e 400 suas casa e hoje eu sei não
[Música]
mesmo assim eu insisti perguntei à pj
que acham posso fazer de suspense
autorização isso não tem piada né
achamos que o diga
hoje o meu pc gusmão pc neste momento
especial estar aqui tá se projetar isso
não é matrix e são as técnicas são
máquina e infelizmente eu conseguir isso
não perguntem como não consegui anual a
chover o que está acontecendo aqui é
muito simples como eu não me deixaram
fazer e eu fiz a mesma eu estou aí que a
especial foi até nós vamos vê-lo chama
super wifi telex fricock janeiro
o avião um atr
o que eu fiz para não sair daqui com
algemas hoje
combinei com um absurdo do tse não foi
quem me acompanhou até agora e é na
língua gestual efe
isto é comunicação entre pc ea sua fã e
este telemóvel era sim filmamos agora
está central depois a ligar faixa etária
inteira passou e usa nenhum site um site
que eu configurei ser mais fácil também
passou mal caiu e ela está no tempo
passou e um exame no site e vai ganhar
lá neste momento login login.asp meu pc
e linguagem máquina não interessa
já criei que os filtros
acho que conseguem todos o que aconteceu
que eu nem meu anel é pontocom passou a
super ténéré esse espírito e conseguiu
com vocês todos
agora provavelmente porque ontem entrou
em vigor uma coisa chamada hush sabe o
que ouviram falar sobre isso a toda hora
queremos a velocidade basicamente o que
o que não há segurança
assim está tomado por porções
é desastrosa e gás como eu facilmente
chega uma platéia em algumas das suas e
disse assim pessoas são donas dos dados
seja qual for a empresa que tem e tem
direito e que a cidade desapareçam de
internet terá dor de cabeça fez tudo
pago com esse pensamento
a questão não é se o mct caixa é quanto
porque hoje facilmente poderia ter
aplicado a todos e como diz saída da
equipe e agora com algemas
[Aplausos]